comment pouvez vous penser que le
patronat les capitalistes aujourd'hui en
quoi que ce soit à gagner du confinement
encore une fois on analysera en main en
bonbons marxisme amateurs parce que non
mais parce que ça permet de liquider une
partie de l'appareil productif et que le
patronat a toujours fait ça simplement
dans quand on parle du peut être faut
pas mettre dans le même sac le medef et
les petites pme
le medef est pas le copain des pme je
viens c'est insupportable cette façon de
kant macron dit on va aider l'entreprise
qui dit pas on va aider les salariés il
dit on va pas augmenter les salaires
on va aider les propriétaires des
entreprises les propriétaires des
grandes entreprises
est ce qu'ils se frottent les mains est
ce que les traders se frotte les mains
par exemple
d'accord c'est quoi le trader s'est pas
de financer l'économie réelle c'est de
jouer sur des os et des et des baisses
là c'est c'est ce et ses festivals pour
eux pour ceux qui ont joué à la baisse
ou à la hausse
évidemment je veux dire il y en a qui
vont jouer à la baisse je verse et c'est
formidable c'est génial va aider baisse
de 14% des remontées de 5% fin c'est le
sait le celle là c'est la fête chez les
traders pour les bourses en ce moment je
veux dire
rappelez vous comment soros ce fait
c'est fait d'aider des sommes d'argent
considérables en pariant sur la sur la
chute de la livre en pariant sur la sur
la dette grecque et c'est donc je viens
quand vous dites le patronat le patronat
le patronat ça dépend de quel patronat
on parle encore une fois c'est bien ce
que je voulais vous entendre dire ce
qu'ils vont en baisse et les petits
patrons ça c'est sûr c'est sur mais bon
il ya un moment il va falloir qu'ils
choisissent leur camp qu'ils arrêtent de
croire que le medef et leurs potes mais
bon ça c'est un problème
[Musique]